[Music]
welcome turn it way up turn it up turn
it up even more I want ya turn this up -
yeah there we go
welcome to fat man be on I'm Kevin Smith
I'm mark barnard we are here at the scum
and villainy Cantina here in Hollywood
right on Hollywood Boulevard man put
your hands together to the folks I
almost forgot what they were supposed to
get together put your hands together so
the folks at home know you're real
ladies jump how the [ __ ] are you man
dude I am I'm good I'm good I'm good yes
so funny we have to play there are
things I know about him that I know why
he's good but he can't talk about it yet
man but soon he he can so is that that's
the big part that's one of it yeah one
of the things I can talk about is I I
was working on a television show about a
year and a half ago yeah eight months
ago time what called Treadstone
yeah the sort of like the Jason Bourne
universe which we couldn't say the words
Jason and or born in the show at all
Sarah yeah literally he's only ever
spoilers referred to as the asset maybe
or like the one that went rogue I think
but the first trailer for Treadstone
dropped
yeah the first [ __ ] telecard says
from the world of Jason Bourne comes
baba blah [ __ ] we had to bend
over backwards to not say that word and
it's right in the [ __ ] marketing they
got one use and they used it use but ya
know the first trailer dropped and that
is really really no it's it's surreal
because I mean you know it do you see
any of your work in the trailer I wrote
that moment I love this line is one but
that's what I did that beat but it's
weird because you spend you know six
months in a room writing
right and you think hey this could be
pretty good but they're also gonna go
and shoot a show and you know no plan
survives contact with the enemy so it's
like the show that you wrote wait again
no plan survives contact with the enemy
where'd you get that war I hear a towel
yeah no fun no plan survives contact
with the enemy that's the idea of that
breaking tomorrow the idea of that is
you can come up with a plan but [ __ ]
once the enemy happens that's right like
they will do not exactly at all what you
expected them to do so you need to be
the angie's up even more as much as you
can
yeah seems low this week sorry folks
you're seeing a little bit backstage up
front you've just to put things on Front
Street Andrew who's a [ __ ] Saint and
is always here with us doing the show
every week is pulling down five rolls
this week because JC who normally pulls
down four rolls himself took off to
Chicago for a family thing a good family
thing so [ __ ] hell man oh my god
Andrew remembering I had a heart attack
a year and a half ago
holy [ __ ] so andrew is uh is just like
kind of he's the octopus man in the
cartoon just pulling a bunch of controls
not to be confused of the Aquaman
octopus who talked to puss it was like
beating the drums and [ __ ] yeah not that
guy
I just watched that baked and it really
works whole [ __ ] movie man but anyway
back to yeah yeah
so yeah the idea is that once you have a
plan the plan will always change once
you actually encounter your opposition
so in making their TV show you write the
show you shoot the show and then you
edit the show and all along those
processes it's possible for the show to
change three different times okay you
know so once you get actors on the stage
once you eat cameras weren't you in
locations once you realize oh [ __ ] that
was supposed to your bridge we don't
have access to a bridge now it's just a
highway said oh he can't jump off a
highway can we how do we rewrite this to
make this work oh this actors great a
comedy we didn't write them in the
comedy let's put a couple of laugh lines
in there oh [ __ ] that guy can't drive
and yet here's a cart chase where he's
driving maybe a different County like it
just becomes a game
of what do we have what can we do how
can this all work together and that's
different than the script that you write
and then there's a script as the the the
show that you shoot and then you take
all of that footage and then you put it
into editing and then that's the last
draft of a TV show just looks to the
last draft of the movie but you can
change wildly the things that you
thought you were gonna do on the script
once you get into post once you realize
oh we didn't get that shot that we
needed but we have another shot here
that's pretty good we don't need 80% of
this interchange between these two
characters we can get all of this across
in a line and we have the line we'll
just cut every other [ __ ] thing you
know and so as a writer you do the best
you can do in the stage that you're
involved in right and then they go off
and make a show and you have no idea
what's gonna look any good or not so to
watch the trailer like I was surprised
and not like Coe is like wow this show
looks pretty good and like I'm not
trying to be like dodgy or weirdly
self-serving like I just had no idea if
the show was gonna be any good and what
do you mean it looks lik or it looks big
like it looks like oh [ __ ] there's a
bunch of like neck punching and a bunch
of like car chasing and because that's
what you want right you want like
[ __ ] a dude who is not Jason Bourne
at all to be like magazine dudes and the
larynx like tostring [ __ ]
inside the head like you just want all
of that I use the [ __ ] flabbergasted
that your idea of big is neck punching
if you do it right good so it looks it
looks it looks like a porn in ISM so
wait when you saw the trailer
you ain't seen anything no you never saw
an episode or as far as I know that I
think they don't do that for you guys
they're not like camacho [ __ ] they they
will when they get to my episode or at
least they should to my episode but like
hey come and look at a cut let us know
if you have any thoughts any notes what
do you think anything we can you know
what do you see that we haven't seen but
at this stage like I wrote the seventh
episode of the run and they are probably
just now cutting - all right so they may
get rounded like later but it's where is
it where is it gonna be USA
and then Amazon international and I
think Hulu day and date which means that
you can watch it at eight o'clock at
night on [ __ ] the USA and they want
to see it again like 10 o'clock that
night it'll be on Hulu
how can a man give it up for Mark he's
got a goddamn show what else you got
going on [ __ ] you're busy I'm busy I I
went to the opening of the Alamo
Drafthouse in LA oh wow is that holy
I've been to others around the country
I've not of course been to this one I
haven't been to any this is my first
Alamo experience period I feel bad that
I'm gonna have to cheat so hard on the
ArcLight like to you guys at home like
la is lousy with great movie theatres
but the [ __ ] Arclight being the gold
standard I think for a lot of people I'm
not that's not me saying it that's the
you know it seems to be most people like
[ __ ] all over pay to see a movie there
it's a gorgeous place with that came out
what 10 years ago 12 maybe 15 at this
point yeah I remember they opened when I
moved out here yeah you told me that's
why you moved oh yeah actually it was
part of the reason one of the tipping
point factors of like you know my wife
had been badgering me for like three
years like let's move to California I
was like nah man New Jersey rocks and
then and then it because it does and
then we went to see election in a packed
multiplex movie theater then it looked
like they were projecting it through a
glass of milk the whole whole time it
was [ __ ] out of focus and I got up
three times and it was the big theaters
it was a big like [ __ ] walk up and
down back and by the end of the movie I
was like that's it we're moving to the
place where movies are in focus and [ __ ]
like that
but in any event yeah so the draft house
it's like a they fetishized movies
they're a fetish Osmond yeah for those
I'm sorry I forgot Arclight
gold-standard the draft house and what
are they calling it a la la and it's
downtown it's literally like right I'm
not getting paid for this either I just
kind of loved it yeah yeah but it's like
oh you can get there easy on the metro
which nobody will use but they say that
you will but it's like right off the
redline in this new thing called the
block so you really take a train there
yeah from like Hollywood and Vine you
can just head down it's like four stops
and then you're in like movie heaven the
for those that don't follow this thing
very closely the Alamo Drafthouse
started in Austin yes and then of course
branched out into other locations around
Texas first and then other places in the
world if I'm if I'm not mistaken I think
there's one in Brooklyn or New York yeah
like they have a video store in there
legit [ __ ] you can go in rent movies
vidiots in the door in in the draft
house Wow
it's a it's a dining theater so like you
sit at your [ __ ] movie see and you
just write down your cars I can't want
to have a cheeseburger I don't have one
of these 50 beers they have on tap
because I want to be drunk while I watch
[ __ ] Hobbes and Shaw why would I not
want a big drop on watching Hobson show
its Hobbes in shop and and they also
have a very strong like repertory
feeling where they're doing like terror
Tuesdays and like Sunday brunch movies
and like it is just it wants to be the
place you go to not just like watch
movies like Lee eat and breathe and
drink movies in no dough and it's
gorgeous
it's lovely I'm glad they finally got
here how many screens twelve [ __ ] really
yeah how bigger well it's like 60 to 100
it's not the yeah it's definitely not
like we have the [ __ ] Chinese black
which has you can fit five hundred
people in there theater it's way more
intimate than it is right yeah which is
nice it's nice it's it's like if it was
in Hollywood it would be a real problem
for the new Beverly all right you know
because it's like oh I want to go in I
want to watch the [ __ ] the abyss on a
Wednesday night like this who's doing
that [ __ ] now
the [ __ ] draught house yeah but did
they show film or they digital they do
both oh [ __ ] yeah so thirty
five-millimeter prints and stuff yeah oh
[ __ ]
[ __ ] I mean Quentin the filmmaker
totally fine in this world Quentin the
movie theater owner might have something
to worry about yeah a little bit little
bit but it's gorgeous you should go if
you should go you probably make it down
there no I do want to go just to see
I've been to the other one so I'd love
to see how they did it here that's
awesome yeah I went to a movie I went to
a premiere of I mean I know it's not
really on brand for what we talk about
here but a Motown documentary Hitsville
USA very cool that I guess that is
airing on Showtime it was [ __ ]
dazzling and wonderful and I never I've
heard the name Barry Gordy my whole life
never once laid eyes on him I don't
think because when they you know they
introduced him in the movie I'm like
that's not Barry Gordy you know and
Barry Gordy was sitting a few rows ahead
of me and [ __ ] so it was it was I'm big
fan of all that music it was a big part
of my childhood and whatnot and this
woven its way into my life and work
forever and watching Barry Gordy and
Smokey Robinson talk about how Motown
got started and got built it's just
beautiful man it's like an American
dream and he based it on like the
Detroit motor factor like the Ford
factory the idea of there was an
assembly line and so he was like we
could do that like with music couldn't
wait and so he set up an assembly line
in like just a little two-story house in
the burbs and [ __ ] oh my god it was
really really good I think it's on
Showtime like this month or next month
did you ever see I think it's 20 feet
from yes where is it one of my secret
like passions man like yeah don't
documentaries do not get me started on
Whitney Houston I am a Whitney Houston
ologist
my friends like oh I'd go deep long and
hard and [ __ ] like the organized soapbox
about what they did and whatnot instead
so there's stuff that I don't really
talk about and
like of course obviously here because we
talk about genre stuff but I loved that
documentary to know ya know the 20 feet
from stardom is all about like Motown
and backup singers like that's the okay
she's out there and we're all back here
but we also can [ __ ] sing and we have
stories and there's the [ __ ] that we've
seen over you know 50 years in the
business and it's fascinating it's an
amazing duck I didn't see any
documentaries what'd you see
I saw I finished the boys oh yeah
everyone another beloved for Rosie I
loved episode 1 oh man it is so good
delivering it kept delivering I am I
I had never seen this guy named Anthony
star before he plays homeland ER holy
[ __ ] dude this guy is amazing you dug
because he does this thing where like
he's Superman for like 60% of the show
and then like that he's Hannibal Lecter
like literally he's flips on a dime and
suddenly he's a sociopath and it's so
much fun to watch because he would be a
sociopath if you're [ __ ] Superman you
would sure like should I save this plane
maybe I'm just saying they'll know we
were here and we don't want that to
happen so maybe all of these people
should just die you guys will be fine
take care like it's it's amazing so good
I mean we talked about a little bit the
last episode I was surprised that [ __ ]
by the first four because it's that oh
this could be bad and it's not bad I
didn't quite realize exactly how [ __ ]
up it was going to get on to Union to
the end and it's oh it's juicy I love it
to death and then there's this one
sequence where there's there's a support
group for survivors of
like accidental casualty survivors or
whatever like people whose lives have
been ruined by like a mistake that a
superhero made this interview with these
two guys one of which is played by
malcolm barrett who was from timeless
and and they says well you know i was a
i'm a writer like i write like marketing
materials for line thought which is the
the company that kind of runs the super
years i kinda i write market muchos for
them and there was one superhero who you
know i'm not gonna say her name but you
know she she kind of she took her liking
to me took a fancy to me like and nobody
wants to [ __ ] the writer i felt it and
the story in the end the punchline to
that story is amazing but now if you
haven't seen the boys you should watch
the boys if you've seen the boys [ __ ]
watch the boys again because it's oh man
it's so good what did i do I have any
there's so many things I want to talk
about but I can't for a little for a
minute read hub minute you know what
else I saw oh good
cuz I was just about to spill when I was
like [ __ ] it and then then you went am I
good yeah go go I didn't see the first
season of the terror I hear it's very
good
okay AMC produced by Ridley Scott the
first season was very much like you know
Antarctic exploration voyage that goes
horribly awry Sasquatch or some [ __ ] I
don't know it's good though right like
has anybody seen it
AMC I'm sure it was on like right after
The Walking Dead any of the 400 times
The Walking Dead is on any given week
the second season is called the terror :
infamy and it's about Japanese
internment camps and and there's a ghost
or some [ __ ] that's kind of loose in an
internment camp I saw the first episode
I don't know is probably a ghost I can
tell well the thing that I loved about
it
is that so specific to that experience
which I know nothing about because I'm
an American and we there's atrocities
that we choose to not pretend that we
had anything to do with like just
imprisoning generations of Japanese
people on under the fear that they might
have had something to do with Pearl
Harbor right and so it's both an
immigration story about people like
nobody loves America quite like an
immigrant does and how these people like
I was born here I moved here I left I
crossed the ocean to come here and
because we were at war with like that
place that was my country that I
voluntarily left you're going to
imprison me and my family with no due
process and no no hope honestly of being
able to get out of here alive and so
what if you imprison these people and
then there's a ghost that they can't get
away from and it's just and it's I love
those stories that managed to take place
in a culture that is both mine and not
mine but has all of the texture of a
world that's lived in it has all of the
sort of cultural kind of like waypoints
and signifiers of ocean that's
frightening and I've never heard of it
before it's like history lesson plus
Japanese horror and it's awesome where
does it on AMC am sets right we
established that yeah yeah yeah so you
should watch that to learn a little
something kids it's educational and
super [ __ ] frightening [ __ ] man I saw
what did I watch this week in game 12
times let me sell you on this
independent film nobody's seen yet it's
real [ __ ] uplifting what's up you
know when a ragtag bunch of kids got to
stop this [ __ ] nut sect chin
[ __ ] from outer space my wife
came into the my office today and she
was like on her way downstairs but she
she's like she comes into my office door
she goes I heard soaring music are you
watching endgame again
and I was good as I was and I was crying
while doing it and she goes turned on a
light and she's like are you
Christ you're crying again and I was
like it never gets bad if you watch it
over and over again the game never ends
uh so [ __ ] good it's so masterful and
[ __ ] I can't like if I got a free hour
I'm like all right I'll [ __ ] watch an
hour and I'll piece together the rest of
the time to like watch it it's the way I
used to eat cereal when I was a kid I'd
start with a bowl of cereal I'd eat the
cereal and there'd be milk left and I
was like ah [ __ ] there's milk left and
so you put more cereal in it and [ __ ]
and then I'll send you're like oh [ __ ]
there's too much cereal I need to add
more milk and [ __ ] then he ate the
cereal there was milk left you like [ __ ]
I got eight more and before you knew it
you killed the box of cereal that's how
I treated any and I was like I'm just
gonna watch a few minutes and [ __ ] and
then all of a sudden my day is shot like
three hours have been [ __ ] passed and
the dogs looking at me like you've been
dressed to take me for a walk for three
[ __ ] hours man I was like I know but
I got invested big-time look I just want
to see if they win still holds up man
it's really well [ __ ] made and but
and I can't get past it my wife is just
she was really like shocked that I could
watch as much as I did and I was just
like hi you know I'm makes me feel good
makes me feel young makes me feel happy
like and also like I learned [ __ ] as a
storyteller I'm like [ __ ] man like
number one I should have a brother it's
just it's that's but unfortunately I
haven't watched anything new although
here don't do it yeah I can I get I'm
just trying to think like we were
talking before the show I'm like what's
happened
what can I talk about in the beginning
of the show like the opening and you
know everything is about stuff we can't
really talk about but I can I mean I
don't think I could I could totally
[ __ ] say this I met Frank Darabont
really yeah [ __ ] dope dude for those
that don't follow that closely he's the
guy who made the
Shawshank Redemption amongst other
things as well as The Walking Dead and
created the series The Walking Dead as
well so yeah I had occasion to kick back
and have a good old conversation with
him man and that was kind of dope
because we both like you know had
breakout years 25 years ago Shawshank 25
years old clerks 25 years old so we kind
of came up not together I'd never met
him before but you know he was talking
about like the 25th anniversary I was
like it's that for clerks too and he
goes oh my god that's right and I was
like when we were on the festival
circuit like me and Mosier like in a
paid in a movie theater to see Shawshank
nobody was there but like we [ __ ]
paid to go [ __ ] see it was a matinee
it was [ __ ] empty and [ __ ] but like I
was on board from year one and [ __ ] and
he was just like I keep meaning to see
clerks it was it was cool though well we
did talk about something professional it
wasn't like hey man let's just [ __ ]
glad handed [ __ ] and the thing that we
talked about is pretty [ __ ] dope so
when I could tell you about it hopefully
I that'll be soon that I will
enthusiasms
enthusiasm yeah it was pretty I don't
know it's I never really meet other
filmmakers and particularly ones have
been like kicking around as long as I
have and stuff so it was kind of it was
cool I I can't say why I said this
[ __ ] shows become like a blind item
column that [ __ ] I can't tell you who
but you know I can't say why but I
posted the picture on Instagram so it
was like I got to keep it private
anymore but like I got to spend some
time with Sylvester Stallone which is so
[ __ ] weird you guys
because he's a lovely man but I've never
met anybody who's been famous for fifty
years and not like internet fame not
like oh well I had a show on once on ABC
no like that [ __ ] are you
talking about me he was [ __ ] world
fan he was famous at the time when they
had publicists to manage image and like
kills stories and newspapers and like
when he couldn't walk across the street
lest he be [ __ ] mobbed by
[ __ ] like real
honest-to-goodness Rocky is what 1977
same years Star Wars yeah yeah and it's
and so talking to that dude it's so
weird to me making references to like
[ __ ] that I make references to but
they're his movies like it's just weird
like yeah I mean you know I did this
book and it was really influenced by my
first blood is like you know I I gave
David Caruso his first job at first
blood really yeah tell me that story oh
by the way you know who's like the most
wonderful person called weathers I
believe it let me tell you about when he
came in to audition for [ __ ] Rockies
and he'll tell you all the stories
because his life is full of stories any
73 years old [ __ ]
that's a podcast right there man it is
totally come down to the bar that'd be
amazing
let's talk about some [ __ ] but uh but
the one thing that I remember him
talking about was how hard it was for
him to make action movies and then
looking at a movie like Avengers in game
and like I mean I guess it's hard but
Hemsworth can walk I can't walk
like you know the [ __ ] that I did in
those movies like there's a picture of
me and Rambo three hanging off the side
of a horse I was hanging off the side of
that [ __ ] horse I take after take
after take it fell down half the times
cuz I can't write a [ __ ] horse
Emsworth my god [ __ ] is that a digital
or like face replacement like that guy
is gonna be beautiful and handsome and
perfect for the rest of his life I'm
broken I never really thought about that
that is a dude who like hung from Cliffs
in cliffhanger yeah like there's no CG
like I know he's hanging from the side
of a [ __ ] mountain meanwhile like 20
years later though like action Chris
Hemsworth and he's like I pretended to
catch a hammer but to be fair he does it
so [ __ ] sexy does oh when when they
go to battle and he catches [ __ ] both
of them like mm-hmm just I thrust with
them and [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I love that moment
let's kill him properly this time like
do it and I love the [ __ ] look that
he had at the ante like the hardcore
like Viking look that was tremendous and
[ __ ] I I'll be honest with you some
mornings I get upset get up really
fairly early I'm usually up by 7
generally up between five seven every
morning and I do obviously wake and bake
and stuff and then I go to work but like
for the first half hour [ __ ] everybody
else that's mine
so I sat there and [ __ ] get really
baked I had this [ __ ] big last caviar
joint this [ __ ] Dom Pablo thing that
just it would take out a small nation
that's so [ __ ] huge smoke that and I
watched [ __ ] cap Thor and Iron Man
fight fan OHS frame-by-frame so like I
watched the scene as though any times
forward but like I was like [ __ ] it man
I like it moves so fast I gotta analyze
this [ __ ] and so I put it in frame by
frame mode it is batshit man when you
watch it that [ __ ] slowly because you
just want to be like Ron you know
because you're seeing [ __ ] about to
connect and it's just like as you watch
it you're like [ __ ] Thanos is an
amazing tactician and fighter and then
you remember like he's a big special
effect but it's so [ __ ] gripping man
did you see somebody on the Twitter I
think they
like some Deeb reddit dive where all of
the things are he cut in like the moment
where Thanos is about to snap at the
very end and he snaps he's like I am
inevitable and he snaps and like it
doesn't work he some dude brilliantly
I'm assuming it's a dude because it's
[ __ ] Sabbath but cuts in like Iron
Man the music so it's just like I am
inevitable and then it's just [ __ ] I
am Iron Man
and then it's all of the [ __ ] fields
were just that music and but he [ __ ]
does it was such style man you know what
I've [ __ ] noticed now more than ever
it spoilers if you haven't seen this
video but the billion dollars were the
people who said I mean the
highest-grossing movie ever made but
when he's like an I am Iron Men and he
snaps he doesn't just [ __ ] snap he
snaps at that [ __ ] like like
look at it it's it's like you know they
[ __ ] go whiteout and [ __ ] but yeah
it's not just like this and [ __ ] it is
[ __ ] you like oh what a brilliant
performance she choice
that's all I've seen alright that's our
upfront material I believe that's it the
foreplay there is also fat man on he-man
fat man on he-man
yeah me and Mark are gonna do go do fat
man Beyond at power con in Anaheim this
weekend we're gonna interview our friend
Rob David who's been working on he works
in the tub he's been working on the DC
Comics like the turned eternity war and
stuff like that so we're gonna go
interview them on stage at power come
Sunday have you Sunday Sunday at 1:30 I
think it's 12:30 I'm gonna just show up
at your house and you drive yes
we'll be there when we get there are you
ready to deep dive into he-men mine ala
jiff he-man is glancing at best right so
there's gonna be a lot of hey keV you
should ask them a question now I'm like
you know the way I'm like a closet
Whitney Houston ologist like I got that
for masters of the universe as well so
I'll be able to [ __ ] ask a bunch of
questions okay God if he I don't know
what it is to get tickets and stuff like
that but if anybody's interested we'll
be recording it of course and I believe
shooting it but if you're interested in
you're anywhere near Anaheim come on
down and see power see you some power
come Sunday at [ __ ] is at 12:30
I think it's 1:30 are you sure no I
think it's 12:30 go to a website
obviously we're on dependable but we'll
be there to do some chat unreliable
narrators other than that that's bit
other housekeeping JC's not here Jamie
it's Shannon's birthday today so Jamie
Caviar's comes to like every [ __ ]
show and practically drag Shannon to
every show and today Shannon's birthday
how old these shent well 20 22
what is the Haunted Mansion
you this is the big five Oh give it up
for Shannon he hit 50 today man I told
him he doesn't look a day over 60 no
[ __ ] a man you're spending your
birthday here the day really Oh
yesterday was your birthday [ __ ] you man
like [ __ ]
that's awesome welcome to the [ __ ] -
I was welcomed you to 50 I'm not there
yet you get to welcome me I'll be there
- you're welcome to the back half yes
does that what they call it they can now
mr. Mark Martin right here man he used
to be a new zone for a living so on this
year's show we charged mark with the
duty of going to the Internet
collecting all the [ __ ] we're going to
talk about this week presenting it as
news of our own give it up for mark he
found the news I apologize I'm so [ __ ]
Bakey tonight I never really get like
Bakey I'm always like pretty Christmas
so you get baekje
yeah but tonight I'm really like [ __ ]
struggling to put [ __ ] together I I
didn't know it was possible at my age to
smoke too much but I did I'm more
watching the show than participating
this really weird it's a weird sensation
welcome to a whole new world what news
you got man we all watch the game of
thrones right [ __ ] yeah love hate we
loved most of it at the end we were like
that and it did some [ __ ] towards the
back yeah half and a half yeah those two
guys Benioff and Weiss who ran that show
and and who sort of steered the ship
mostly great they they wrapped up their
time at HBO and we're kind of like
shopping themselves around Hollywood and
they were supposed to do a show for HBO
after Game of Thrones right called
Confederate they were Confederate about
a world like what happens if the South
won or something right which it turned
out the world didn't want yeah like the
world reacted very poorly that
announcement but then it was like well
hey man [ __ ] it they're doing Star Wars
anyway like they were doing their own
Star Wars I got a trilogy because they
were handing out trilogies to everybody
but us
[ __ ] a man like Oprah in cars there was
just [ __ ] flinging trilogies into the
crowd they don't give you your own
trilogy just make your own that's what I
say fair enough but I'm taking one of
theirs as well
so wait a second yes finish the thought
and I'll jump in okay so we have been
talking a couple weeks ago about this
like arms race for giant producers like
yes Shonda Rhimes and Ryan Murphy ended
up in Netflix yes massive million dollar
deals and these guys naturally HBO was
like oh my god [ __ ] stay here lock
them down why would we not want to do
that you can have all the money and you
want
taury HBO you know who has more money
netflix oh really yeah so Netflix said
Netflix said how would you like to come
here and do whatever the [ __ ] you want
to do for as long as you want to do it
and we'll pay you the GDP of like a
couple of small countries and they said
sure really
nine-figure deal this guy signed to go
and there's like no decimals and that
nine figures only commas like I also got
a nine figure deal at Burger King if you
just get rounding down dude what is wait
a second six figure be like a hundred
thousand seven figure be a million eight
figure be tens of thousands and millions
nine figures there's hundreds of
millions I mean what is that for that is
what do you get for that much money you
get that journal life pretty much you
get firstborns and second borns if you
want but yeah so they will now
exclusively make television shows for
Netflix and the presumption is like man
if you can make Game of Thrones work
you'll make everything mad you've got to
have another one in you just like
they're like we do hold on hey george RR
martin do you have another one in you
could you write some more books please
[ __ ] got any more that sweet dragon [ __ ]
but that happens all the time in Holland
so wait what happens to the Star Wars
movies yeah it's still safe this is a TV
deal so they got a deal with Netflix and
a deal with Disney yup wow man I got a
foot in both worlds Weiss but yet Warner
Brothers used to do that a lot like they
they wanted to be in the Wachowskis
business so bad as I hey we made the
matrix which made gazillion [ __ ]
dollars you know what we'll do
everything else you guys want to do when
the hope said another one of these will
be the matrix and then you get like
Jupiter ascending see was that what it
was called yeah
Jupiter ascending ascending dude it
wasn't bad he's he's okay no let him
talk you out of it man listen you love
you I ain't [ __ ] advocating for
Jupiter ascending man that's the yoga
hosers of Wachowski brothers movies
needs the [ __ ] love man Mila Kunis is
a [ __ ] toilet cleaning empress from
outer space like the bees all seem to
love and but it's also like that bad as
pounding on in the galaxy and I don't
know hey yeah it's not bad it's not good
very inventive
it is super interesting yeah it's it's
breathtaking but they also did Speed
Racer which is like gorgeous
I [ __ ] love Speed Racer I can't say
that that's good either but I also don't
care it's daring in it and it's
beautiful to look at the end of that
movie makes me tear up every time
because it's just it's a heroic it's the
mythic journey of this guy who finally
discovers here's what I'm supposed to be
here's what I'm supposed to do and I'm
the best in the world at it and watching
that stuff like it's it's gorgeous
there's a monkey in the trunk which I am
I'm not on board with like monkeys and
trunks of [ __ ] just generally like
monkeys and drunks tend to ruin most
things that you put monkeys and/or
trunks in true but but yeah so this is
Netflix banking on Weiss and Benny off
to be able to create another game
for them so with all that money when
they say something like that like 100
million 200 million what is it it's
they're being very unspecific hundred
million bucks that how long is that for
a couple of years two three for you does
that mean like here's 100 million you
got pay people out of this where they
just get to keep the 100 million for
themselves they get they get their
company whatever that company is will
come there and from that X number of
hundreds of million dollars they then
have to run the company but that is not
the budgets for any of the shows that
they create that is still above and
beyond that's separate money - like oh
you want to make again I don't know game
of bones great we will then cut you a
check for the hundred million dollars
you need to make a season of game of
bones
so Belvin beyond the three hundred
million dollars we gave you to just put
an office in here
oh yeah that's your understanding of
these things yeah I really failed in my
professional life I just thought it was
always like you know it's a hundred
million dollar deal and out of that like
you got to pay for the movie didn't [ __ ]
him whatever in the overhead and
whatever is left if you want to keep it
go ahead we'll look the other way yeah
they gave them hundreds of millions of
dollars just to walk across the [ __ ]
Street on the hopes that they will make
them billions they spent hundreds of
millions such an [ __ ] it's okay
there's still time it's true I was doing
well in life and [ __ ] but those guys
cracked the code wow that's crazy money
good for them yeah HBO not mad or
anything anybody check on HP over there
hey girl you're right they were doing
like [ __ ] what was his name
Joffrey's little brother just stepped up
on the [ __ ] ledge went off
well did they was it tough to lose
though or maybe cheap to lose them maybe
that frees up a lot of cash it probably
does and I think that how's the time for
us to go in a [ __ ] HBO with crazy
ideas and sure we only need tens of
millions yeah yeah bargain-basement you
like dragons drag on this can we have a
show I mean it is kind of like the time
like you know HBO max now is not just
gonna be HBO but like you know it's
their own confident app we talked about
how that's the worst name for anything
I've ever heard ever you don't like HBO
max that is like the first idea theater
of a bunch of like 60-year old white
guys like what do we call it HBO kids
seem like HBO but more chemical in each
bill more no no no no no no wait I got
it HBO Plus [ __ ] no Disney just got Plus
okay hold on HBO max yeah you're
describing it like it's the poochy of
streamers it's the Poochie name of
streamers
yeah at least they didn't call it HBO to
the max I think it's misleading because
as HBO in the title and it's like well
how do we dilute the awesome brand that
we have over here which seemed to mean
like selective and curated yeah man now
it's gonna be everything and also more
yeah but I also feel like aside from
like whatever it does to HBO it's just
how do you know that it's the Warner
Brothers app unless they call it the
Warner Brothers have like why wouldn't
you call it bugs you know I'm saying in
honor of [ __ ] Bugs Bunny you got to
call the app something [ __ ]
invented something called it Hulu and
now we all say yes [ __ ] so why not just
[ __ ] call it bugs though like it's
got everything the icon is a little
picture of Bugs Bunny I know I'm not
getting a lot of support here but [ __ ]
all y'all
these these are also the people that
when a lawsuit or network they're like
you know who the mascot is the fraud is
from that one episode that people love
but nobody remembers that's true that's
a big part of our job yeah daba daba
daba you big michigan a frog all right
so that's it for benny of him wise they
got all the money in the world all the
money and they're just gonna cry himself
to sleep in fistful of thousand-dollar
bills
I imagine this means we're gonna be
getting great entertainment not kind of
what I hope so
you know who has plans it was great
entertainment Miller and Lord but we
love them we do love the Miller Lord or
the geniuses behind spider-man into the
spider-verse as well as movies that I
[ __ ] like can't believe how much I
wound up liking those 21 Jump Street
movie yeah
and what else do they do that is
something else that I love lego movie
[ __ ] how could I forget and cloudy with
a chance of meatballs which is also
whatever [ __ ] uh no I'm that's very
sweet but the lego movie is like one of
the most brilliant things ever [ __ ]
made it a lego movie two is enjoyable
but doesn't come close no and that's not
like you know I'm [ __ ] not it you know I
don't even know why I tagged in it but
like [ __ ] that lego movie is amazing so
they are developing a suite of TV shows
based on spider-man for Sony for all
right wait say that again live-action TV
shows TV shows TV shows settings
spider-man universe because Sony has the
rights to spider-man still even though
Marvel shares them yeah
Sony is the one who actually makes the
spider-man movies and so they now have
the right to spider-man on the nine
hundred some-odd characters that come
along with spider-man they have that for
a long time they have it for a lot so
wait they're gonna do live-action shows
yep for whom for Sony I mean does Sony
of a network know they'll sell it
elsewhere
so it's Sony is it was a brothel dude
nothing will be on crackle there
produces Sony's mega net their the
studio and somebody who else will be
airing it right and what what are the
ideas here did they they won't say all
they say is we are developing a handful
of live-action shows using Sony's Marvel
counter
which they were like 900 of them we're
figuring out a way to develop the show
so that each of their own unique
experience but also related we've been
talking to a lot of potential teammates
for trying to do something not like
anything else has been done on TV it'll
be a little while before it all comes
together and it's on the air but I think
it is going to be something really
special blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah they also signed a 9 picture deal 9
figure deal at Sony Pictures Television
really them do whatever they wanted TV
what is this say right there about
Netflix hopefully we'll know in the next
few months where it'll be and what the
schedule would be was all Miller would
say when asked whether the invent
eventual destination would be Netflix I
mean those dudes in charge is a good
thing I don't know if more spider-man's
good thing about me look I'll always
take more spider-man I just don't know
if there's a hunger for it but I'm on
board I think everything they did with
the character the characters was
fantastic we're spectacular I should say
so yeah I'm in yeah like an and I I have
faith in those guys me too that they
won't dilute it by doing too much of it
unless it makes sense you know however
they're gonna find it but it's weird it
sounds like now they'll be I mean it's
all Marvel right but it's not Marvel
Studios this side of it I mean Marvel
will have some consultation but it's not
a Marvel jammy-jam right not a Kevin
Feige thing no but neither was
spider-man into the spider-verse
know so technically it can be done it
can be done yeah that was any passing if
anybody could [ __ ] figure it out Lord
and Miller man they did a fantastic job
with that movie oh my god that movie's
so [ __ ] good yeah remember when at
one point they got into a movie some
version of a Spider Man who said whip it
out yeah but it's like whip it out man
like oh my god when I heard that I'm
like we're in a [ __ ] brave new world
what's next did you watch it in the GI
Joe movies yeah otherwise I have vague
memories of Joseph gordon-levitt
screeching and [ __ ] like wow when he was
Cobra Commander yeah they made two
movies judge Bruce Willis was another
I'm one of them right he was Joe himself
he was Jill himself and the rock was in
the second one and Channing Tatum was
for like half an hour yeah they made two
movies which did relatively well they
made something like six hundred million
dollars worldwide both of then there was
talk that they were gonna cross them
over with transformers yeah
which they never did but they are making
a Snake Eyes movie that makes sense yeah
for reals and then they're spinning it
off into a fourth movie that they're not
saying yet what it is but I personally
don't know if I need more GI Joe I was
just testing your read I think are they
it's is he gonna be silent the whole
time because I'd like to audition man
I'm dropping the weight [ __ ] I could
be your snake guys is this is it are
they gonna tell some story about this is
why he doesn't talk yeah it's gonna be
like the origin of Snake Eyes so you
will talk and then and then won't
anymore at some point somebody will
dance and also like it'll have ninjas
which are always cool right you know so
keeps the brand alive
how did Hobbes and Shaw do for the fast
and furious brand well I mean it did
really well it's something in length
three hundred and forty million dollars
domestic something like six hundred
million worldwide in like two or
whatever it is it's not the highest
grossing of The Fast and the Furious
movies but it's doing pretty [ __ ]
well right now the next one will be a
traditional Fast and the Furious yeah
they're doing fast nine I think right
now and then you'll get like a Hobbes to
show older those cars stealing kids man
like when we started this journey seemed
to be a long time ago ya know Vin Diesel
was like young and buff and like his
skin was good and and now he's like 52
he's 52 years old
I mean good he looks great I wish I look
like [ __ ] that at 49 but like fast
[Laughter]
you know nobody in 52 is really that
fast
yeah but you know I didn't know that
[ __ ] we're all old man we really are but
as long as you keep hashtag family alive
you can keep going for a while this this
is my favorite thing of the week I think
that I saw okay a trailer dropped I want
to say was yesterday on the 20th
anniversary of Bowfinger which if you've
never seen Bowfinger is maybe the
greatest movie about the making of
movies mm-hmm and the love and the joy
and Outsiders making a movement
Outsiders making the movies directed by
Frank Oz starring Steve Martin and Eddie
Murphy on the 20th anniversary of that
movie Dolomites is my main trailer
dropped starring Eddie Murphy which holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you haven't seen this
trailer yet my god take a peek at it man
it's coming on Netflix so if you got
Netflix you get to watch it for free and
[ __ ] Eddie Murphy playing Rudy ray Moore
yes and it's directed by Craig Brewer
yeah with a script by Scott and Larry
the guys that I know they did [ __ ]
recently but I always think of them as
the People vs Larry Flynt and them in
the man on the moon and the what is the
Ed Wood Ed Wood guys but what are they
done recently the the People vs OJ yeah
people who that was them was their big
Jim and then something else but this
looks absolutely [ __ ] phenomenal yeah
because Rudy ray Moore if you don't know
it was like a failed stand-up comedian
in this 70s in the early 70s who wanted
to somehow make a career for himself and
so decides well like I'm gonna go see
shaft and I can't I'll be that guy
seconds your effect
you're not funny and you don't have any
Talent is that what [ __ ] I'm gonna
make my own movie we're on the star of
this movie I'm gonna know kung fu and
I'm gonna be cool and I'm gonna do all
and he made the movie on a [ __ ]
shoestring like by himself and just
improved and willed his way to becoming
a movie star and his version of shaft
essentially totally he was created his
own character
gentlemen to the Dolomites and so this
is the making of that for is it's the
Rudy ray Moore story starring Eddie
Murphy which again like having Scott and
Larry right it makes sense because it
does share DNA with that would yeah it
is about and they they're so good at
doing Outsiders but it's about people
who want to do something that like I
love [ __ ] like this because it's
literally my life story every time so
they do an outsider's movie I'm like I
was [ __ ] there and should when I
watched the trailer I it's wrong to say
like I fell in love with Eddie Murphy
again because I've never fallen at
eleven-thirty Murphy but I was so
[ __ ] delighted to see Eddie Murphy
like working like it's I hope it leads
to him maybe hosting Saturday Night Live
for the first time and it's not just him
working it's him being funny it's really
working like [ __ ] working all of his
chops he's [ __ ] gifted insanely
gifted man and like watching him in that
trailer you're like [ __ ] yes that's the
one I want to see like I was trying to
explain to somebody who was a youth
today who couldn't quite understand why
it means so much because Eddie Murphy
was the funniest man on the planet and
walked away from stand-up comedy when
nobody was bigger ascent of comedy that
he was like he it was a couple of albums
and then Eddie Murphy delirious and
Eddie Murphy raw which played in [ __ ]
theaters and like made something like 70
80 million dollars in like nineteen late
eighties maybe nine money which for a
stand-up movie is ridiculous
and then just didn't do comedy anymore
was funny in movies and he would be in
these [ __ ] Eddie Murphy and like
wickedly talented but I can't imagine
that's like Jimi Hendrix being like you
know what I just want to sing now which
anymore if he did it a certain point
Eddie Murphy was just had a girl wants
to party all the time not that girl my
girl wants to party all the time
produced by Rick James who you can hear
okay that's right he's Becca
that but yeah just to see him like a
live wire again it's so [ __ ] nice it
looks it really engaging as [ __ ] Craig
Brewer did hustle and flow as well his
Black Snake Moan which I [ __ ] loved
and didn't he do a Tarzan or something
like that maybe no he was working on it
but didn't do the Footloose he did the
Footloose remains right so weird i
conflate those two in my head
Tarzan and Footloose same [ __ ] movie
but he's doing he directed this isn't he
directed someone else with Eddie Murphy
coming to America too he's directing
that yes and they got the whole [ __ ]
cash to come back for coming to America
too
so like Arsenio Hall is back as his best
friend James Earl Jones is back
Paul Bates is back as his number two
like Johnny most just signed on Oh
[ __ ] Shari Headley who played yes yeah
everybody's [ __ ] back that offense at
and I said who else waste Wesley Snipes
Wesley so Wesley Snipes is also in Elam
I dolomite yeah so I guess everyone had
a great time keep working Wesley keep
those taxes paid [ __ ] and and
Leslie Jones is in it and some like it
she could roll when is it coming out I
know they're just making it as December
they start shooting like in a couple of
weeks I remember the first one did come
out in December - it is a Christmas
movie if I remember correctly wow man I
can't [ __ ] wait that jump to the top
of the list sounds like they're doing
deep cuts continuity man [ __ ] that's
cool that's very [ __ ] cool it makes
me happy as hell like I I cannot wait
for the the the James Earl Jones asan's
or it's like listen that it's not dead
yet keep [ __ ] working
because I'm afraid for him it's like in
his 80s I mean what a big year for him
man he's he's lion king mm-hmm well I
guess this is next year but still yeah
you know what being a life for him man
holy [ __ ]
remember for a long period of time like
you know he's all I remember feel the
dreams that she he's always consistently
active but remember for a long [ __ ]
time like the big gig where you heard
him all the time was this is CNN like he
made more money off of that than
everything else in his career combined
is that true yeah how do you know that
I've read an interview it's like they
paid me like every time that runs he
gets paid and my [ __ ] that is still the
signal identification for CNN it's like
Eddie Van Halen made more money doing
the de tar solo for beat it then every
other Van Halen - album combined because
it's just so [ __ ] thriller
because it's like oh yeah I get paid
every time that [ __ ] and it sold more
albums than any other album on the face
of the planet
Wow this is like this is CNN I put all
of my kids through school it means I
don't have to give a [ __ ] about anything
ever again
right I want to show up not showing up
[ __ ] you I'm CNN [ __ ] how many how many
do you mean like do you think they even
gave him direction in which to go or do
you think they were like anyway he says
it's gonna sound cool it's gonna sound
like Darth Vader so if I'm like let's
let him say it however he says it then
he picked cuz you go he goes this is CNN
you could go this is CNN this is CN I
would like to see like the reel of
outtakes
so this is line [ __ ]
CNN get it right we'll make you a
billionaire that's that oh yeah man I
can't wait to [ __ ] see that movie
that movie sounds great the [ __ ]
dolomite when do we get to see dolomite
soon um I think it's soon I think it's
in the next month or so like that I mean
[ __ ] I hope good for Netflix cuz
who's gonna make that movie in this day
and age you know what I'm saying but
like when you see that trailer you're
like how could they have not made that
movie up until this moment in time I
thought it was a legit theatrical
release and I didn't until it got to the
end the clunky metal flakes okay but why
is this not in movies I think that's how
they roll right they own don't didn't
they buy the Egyptian so that it can put
you know because there was some rule
about you have to have movies playing a
movie theater in order to qualify for an
Oscar and they're like alright and they
bought a movie we got this [ __ ] a way
to do it
that was their roma play it was like
honor we're gonna own the Oscars how do
we qualify done what else you got that
is all I got
you [ __ ] me it's a slow news week huh we
talked for an hour
time flies man give it up for Markie
brought you the news
I think I keep thinking of that line
from Superman where the pilot is looking
out when they went near the wing I'm the
[ __ ] engine in the wings like what do
we got I don't know we got something
just fly yeah I don't know just fly
that's tonight we're just flying we're
just flying
I had a before we dive into anything
else I had a [ __ ] have you ever had
powdered peanut butter
yeah only at your house because you gave
me with bamboo [ __ ] things yeah yeah
but those are like but that's not even
powdered I'm talking about like they
make powdered peanut butter where it's
like just literally peanut powder and if
you want you could have water too and it
would turn into like some sort of peanut
e sauce thing people put it on the top
of like energy drinks and [ __ ] like that
is that an attack method and like you're
throwing [ __ ] powder peanut butter
[ __ ] you just gum up their face
you totally good cuz it happened to me
today man I was [ __ ] in my car driving
and I had a can of this [ __ ] and I was
like this is a perfect blast of [ __ ]
protein and so I opened it up and took a
mouthful and it's literally like taking
a mouthful of flour so instantly I like
- while the moisture just sucks out of
your mouth but it's not unpleasurable
because you look door
then you gotta grab a dragging [ __ ]
quick down it and [ __ ] like that but I
was doing it in [ __ ] traffic and I
had to do a quick stop short and poof it
like what [ __ ] down me and the person
to my left saw it and was like alright I
don't even know why I told that story
but the this part of the show ladies and
gentlemen is are we signing it because
it says for you both to sign for me
I'm glad you read the instructions also
before we go further man what I saw this
online who brought us that Howard the
dock thing yeah
jump up to the wall man let's find out
what this is about
the Howard the you know I'm working on a
show with Marvel Howard the Duck
animated series for Hulu so I saw this
on line I guess a couple days ago or
something like that and I thought the it
was number one cute clever [ __ ] title
never give you great [ __ ] idea who
are you my name is Ernie Trinidad
independent filmmaker all right give it
up for a man he's one of us and what the
idea is the idea is you're doing
documentary about Howard the Duck the
movie yes
I'm sure many people here probably are
in the camp that think Howard the Duck
is trash what are the worst movies ever
but there are people and I've met I've
interviewed a number of people already
who have a genuine like for this movie
that people say there is no reason why
is she like this piece of crap right and
I basically thought that last year last
July I was thinking everybody is making
crowdfunded documentaries about their
favorite franchises police academy
Fright Night Hellraiser an AI Brunel
Street you name it and I'm like how come
no one's ever done out of the duct and I
just got quiet
when'll I did my research and right then
and there I said we're doing this a year
later we started tell me so [ __ ] I
give it up for art right there man
[Applause]
so what what difficulties have you
encountered this part the biggest
difficulty is our crowdfunding campaign
crashed and burned as bad as the movie
were honoring which I find totally
ironic and totally embrace because I
just told it like they can okay this is
we want to do this we're not getting the
funding for bucket we're doing it so
it's like total girls style independent
filmmaking just reaching out to whoever
we can get whoever we can get great if
then we'll just keep pursuing it
pursuing it
keep filming until we get everybody we
feel we need to make a proper
documentary to show people that
especially in this day and age where
everybody's like they hate this they
hate that they you don't like what you
like it if people says you suck because
you like that it's like who cares what
they think it's what do you think what
do you feel inside if Howard the Duck
makes you feel good and I've met people
you've actually liked one person we
interviewed actually said she had a
crush on Howard the Duck when she was a
kid so it's a documentary that I would
like to see man look at Jack yeah that
happened in the movie so totally opened
I'm just reaching out to whomever and I
saw you were here I may have taken hey I
was gonna try to reach you at a Comic
Con is like it's gonna be just too
hectic this is definitely the place to
do it
how can anyone at home or whatever or
help basically I actually have a well I
already forgot what the crowdfunding is
hey not IndieGoGo that's when I blew it
I'll go funding a GoFundMe we have a
good fund me going or our traveling
budget not that not asking people's like
hey send me here send me there but our
problem is I'm funding this out of
pocket doing what I can but our travel
budget is to allow us to go wherever we
need to go to get these interviews right
so we got chip sidarsky who was totally
behind it he wants to do it chip but he
chip he's a guy who's
the redefine howard the duck and yet the
most recent has done an incredible job
over at marvel so he would be a great
get yes anis he's totally game he wants
to do he's like but he's like I'm in
Toronto I'm like yeah we'll figure it
out and I have a couple people I'm
meeting with Samantha Gerber Steve
Rivers daughter and I got to go to
Sacramento for that so that's more
travel that comes out of pocket so I'm
starting that campaign not to fund the
movie I just we need just traveling I
just just to go get these interviews for
the people so give these people the
audience someone to listen to that they
would actually like to hear they don't
want to hear about from people like some
so from comic-con they want to I want to
and they want to hear from actual people
involved in the industry and also people
who actually worked at making the movie
and just any journal folk who actually
show that there are fans of the film
which is what I wanted to you guys were
like great obviously Kevin is doing the
Howard the Duck the Animated Series next
year it's like that would be I would
definitely got to reach out to him to
see if he's available to do it who's
your white whale
my white whale yeah you're gonna be this
crazy mission Tim Robbins there's ed
Gale who I did interview says there's no
way in hell you're gonna get Tim Tim
Robbins Tim Robbins he apparently he
does not like to talk about Howard the
Duck is that right that's straight from
Ed yeah I said you're never gonna get
Tim Robbins he does not like to talk
about it I'm like oh I'll try I mean I
would imagine like the white whale is
George Lucas I gotta know cuz if anybody
doesn't want to talk about it I imagine
it's him I got it
well I didn't get a no from Lucas
himself I got a no from Skywalker Ranch
publicity he said it's like he's busy
doing his philanthropic work for his
museum and whatnot only read between the
lines that says duck no
but he's opening a museum in LA so I say
duck yes yes there you go all right man
we'll arrange it through the bar these
cats I'll happily come here we could do
an interview awesome are you from the
area are you from the area yes I mean I
didn't hear the boom we've just saved
travel cost right there sweet and
sometimes it helps you get one interview
a bunch trickle down and stuff like that
so that's easy as [ __ ] to do man and you
know why because it's a [ __ ] great
title Howard the doc that deserves to be
real give it up Ernie man Howard the doc
and Mark as well yeah okay we've come to
the Q & A portion of the evening ladies
and gentlemen that's the part of the
show where we open the floor up to you
folks the audience and ask we answer
questions that you guys are we answer
questions you guys are asking [ __ ] I'm
so bacon we're getting it done man yeah
man we're gonna talk is what I'm getting
that and jay-z is not here of course as
we previously mentioned Natan Andrew
have found us thank you
some folks to ask question ask questions
and there's one already what's your name
sir so my name is not important but I am
The Wizard of Menlo actually message
both of you or rather a did you like it
there's a way we do things what's your
name man oh is it a memoir we give it up
for The Wizard of Menlo you don't write
the [ __ ] into it man you went right for
my [ __ ] you got to kiss me first
maybe rub a nipple or something like
that baby like wit or metal only
we'll get player I'll do the fair enough
who are you man what's going on so I
mean I've been watching you since far
too young like before like 10 years old
dogma
James Hannah Bob strike back so I'm very
excited for the reboot I've seen all of
the behind the scenes I've watched the
trailer all that [ __ ] Castle Rock sure
yeah episode 6 the [ __ ] fantastic
voice of God all that [ __ ] it was really
good the best episode in the season
haven't actually watched the last
episode yet because I don't like
finishing stuff wait what in general so
you love Game of Thrones question is
what is the dumbest and smartest thing
you've done well hi and I'm talking
cloud 9 cloud 10 you what's the dumbest
smartest thing you've done while very
drunk and I'm talking verge of blackout
Wow Wow
virgin hold on first off we [ __ ] went
so fast all right I forgot to talk about
the prizes generally we ask people ask
really good questions and [ __ ] and if
they do they win a prize number one
that's a great question so you're
definitely winning a [ __ ] prize the
prize this week of course as always is
our good friend deacon who works over at
the 40x company
Gabe's gave us tickets three rounds of
tickets three of two piece to go see a
movie at the 40x theater that got one
here at La alive it is an incredible
experience see a movie in 40x it what is
the movie what Hobbs and shops in the
shop like if you got a kidney stone that
you don't want anymore
go see Hobbs in Shona 40x theatre cuz it
will work that [ __ ] right out because
the seats moving around and it's
relevant every time somebody gets shot
there's like it's like a shoot that you
don't have you guys done the D box in
like Cinemark it's I think comparable at
least in terms of this I've been to a D
boxes close but this is
unreal the 4dx goes way beyond it man
sounds dirty
I know D box sounds like I'm like you're
making fun of somebody you [ __ ] D box
but this is like Universal Studios like
the the the that's their version right
these cats for DX aw well this one's
that regal it says is that what the LA
Live is you gotta go if you haven't seen
a movie in 40 X go see it we talk about
it all the time man it's a fantastic
experience so who you're gonna get a
pair of tickets you're also gonna get
this beautiful signed print by our good
friend Nick Gonzalez man give it up for
Nate he does the show art make me
selling these after the show as well so
you can buy him if you're not lucky
enough to win one of these so we give
you that we give you that you were also
gonna get I got hats from caviar that's
the weed I smoked I will take that I
can't wear it obviously but we could
take yeah don't want to [ __ ] that fro no
and then you'll also walk away with a
signed copy of a hit girl in Hollywood
which is a miniseries I did for Mark
Miller and I did with pernil who's been
here on the show so big [ __ ] booty the
wedding off I know really [ __ ] my
blonde and I've got 20 bucks all right
so back to the question the dumbest the
best and worst things yes you've done
long very very high and black a bit
won't verge a blackout cuz you opportune
owners I know the dumbest thing so let's
go dumb smart dumb or awesome you start
with dumbest go ahead all right I I want
okay statute limitations is probably on
my side I was graduating from high
school so I was I was a little younger
than 21
earlier drinking underage and we were
the high school I was graduating from we
were graduating on like the main field
that we had where it was like oh he's
the baseball diamonds is a football
field he was the track you know that
[ __ ] and and so I draw
my car around the bases I shoe at night
very late it was late at night and like
I drove my car around the bases and like
slid into home
well what caught what was this this was
a 1987 Plymouth Gran Turismo which they
don't make anymore
it had a spoiler on the back which led
gave the impression flame of speed and
he flame no flames you know some wood
paneling because it also was like we
made a car to wood don't you want one
but yeah so I got drove around the bases
and like [ __ ] that up good and then
drove through what was eventually going
to be like a graduation with the chairs
and [ __ ] and so like I just tore up that
[ __ ] lawn
and then like got up the rise and like
back onto the street and then saw like
sirens in the back hey somebody heard
and saw me [ __ ] up their graduation
field this would have been a New York
but uh and then the next day I get to go
to that field and sit on that in those
[ __ ] chairs and just listen to room I
don't know mister I guess yeah that's
the dumbest thing that I've done while
under the influence the smartest thing
I've ever done while high is tusks
that's why I'm here actually
hands down though you'll find a bunch of
people out there to be like no he's
wrong but I honestly feel that I love
that movie and it came from being stoned
I've seen it four times
Oster several times more but thank God
it wasn't a series you wouldn't know
what happens at the end like I hope he
gets out probably there was a detective
who could help that was so that was the
smartest thing I've ever done I like I
was struggling to come up with the
dumbest thing I've ever done
hi but I've never done anything dumb
while hi I have done dumb things while
drunk you've been drunk
I have I you know I'm not gonna say I
used to drink but when I was in high
school that was the option and I hated
it I liked you who better than [ __ ]
liquor like sugar was my [ __ ] thing
so when we all got into the mandatory
junior senior age of [ __ ] like we're
gonna [ __ ] party man like I was still
stuck in like wait Friday night that's
when we make crank phone calls and [ __ ]
and order pizzas and send them people's
houses and [ __ ] and now there was this
weird forced socialization down at like
snake lake where somebody had a [ __ ]
course party ball and he all sat around
and [ __ ] tried to pump it until it
was foam and then drink beer it all
seems so [ __ ] depressing like why was
everyone in such a rush to like [ __ ]
like drink that's what our parents
didn't show so I was never really into
it but I was teenagers so sometimes went
along with it and my friend Mike
bellicose who was the guy in clerk's
who's when Dante goes 37 my girlfriend
sucked 37 days in a row that's the dude
he was supposed to be Silent Bob that's
why I wrote the role of Silent Bob for
Mike bellicose so we're at a party Mike
balco's his senior year and it's for
Bella's birthday so it's in the fall
this being October and I for some reason
I named it something for some reason I
loved Animal House and so I just you
know wanted to be [ __ ] Bluto so badly
at the party and so Bluto if you
remember seems mental house like takes a
bucket thing of what southern comfort or
whatever [ __ ] drinks it down Jack
Daniels drinks down then smashes the
bottle so they had a think this might be
a 1.5 liter maybe not but they started
making pop off vodka had a you know they
was always in glass bottles yeah this
was the year they started putting in
plastic bottles like so two liter soda
thing okay so we're at Billy's birthday
crowds not even there yet and [ __ ]
they're like Smitty what do you want to
drink and I was a Kip me [ __ ] of Smitty
last name is Smith so in high school
there were bunch of people are probably
so frog and I said give me to pop off
and so all night long I had this thing
of pop of vodka 1.5 liter and it was
plastic so you could squeeze it so I
didn't mix it or anything like that and
I didn't have a cup I just literally
Drake from the thing and I would [ __ ]
squeeze it so that I was forcing [ __ ]
vodka into my system like some sort of
party animal within a half an hour of
the party started I was retired - Mike's
sisters bedroom
Nelly bellicose he's like stay here
you'll be safe
close the [ __ ] door I know where the
lights were I don't know anything
[ __ ] I knew Bella's room well and I
knew the downstairs but I never went
into Nellie's room and [ __ ] and I was
blitzed out of my [ __ ] mind just so
[ __ ] beyond drunk so I'm feeling sick
I've drank so much oh you know if I
could probably alcohol poisoning at this
point so I start grabbing things to puke
into just [ __ ] randomly bla bla bla
I'm [ __ ] couldn't [ __ ] move and
then my girlfriend came in at one point
and she's like you alright I was like I
think I'm gonna die she's like all right
I'm gonna go get drunk and she laughed
and then and then finally like I was
like I gotta go home they got me up and
my mom came and picked me up and my mom
brought me home my dad had gone to work
already he worked late at nights and
[ __ ] so it was just me and my mom my
sister and brother were out of the house
at this point and so my mom could have
been so [ __ ] horrible you know and
just destroyed my life
but I was so [ __ ] drunk that I was
beyond honest with her and super [ __ ]
grateful and appreciative and
complimentary apparently so like I'm so
drunk she's like what what did you do
and I was like we went to bellies his
belly's birthday and I got so drunk I
threw up in everything mom everything
and stuff but you know what your best
mom that ever lived
I'm not just saying that cuz I'm drunk
I'm saying it cuz it's [ __ ] true and
I didn't curse in front of my mother and
she was charmed by the whole thing so
she was like you know instead of being
like you're [ __ ] grounded she was
like you know you probably shouldn't do
this time yeah but tell me again what a
good mother is so we sat out around
talking it was actually wonderful
instead so why stupid because the next
[ __ ] morning I went up to bellies to
help clean up and [ __ ] and ms bellicose
met me at the door and she's like you're
not allowed back in the house for a
while Kevin Smith and I said why and
[ __ ] Nellie came out his sister and
she was like because you puked in every
one of my drawers man I was so drunk I
just kept opening drawers and go like
systematically puked in every one of her
choices like I had to throw away all my
t-shirts my underwear [ __ ] you Kevin
Smith dumbest [ __ ] thing in the world
man you guys want to compete with that
that was a dumb one oh that was writer
right so like I assume a lot of your
[ __ ] came out of being drunk no no no I
used to hate is the assumption that all
writers are drunk or high yeah I mean
Stephen King cocaine you know you just
got a it's weird what a weird stares I
put you're right it's true everybody in
the arts and Wayne was what did he do I
don't know but you can imagine what he
must have done the lamest drugs in the
world he'd be like I may paint a fence
well listen the man still holds the
record for the amount of n words in a
Britain right so like I mean is the desi
the record for what for the N word in
written text well the Edward I thought
you for some reason I thought you were
saying he holds the record for the most
written words I'm like how do you know
that like that's amazing
Shakespeare holds that he is created
words the most what were created words
he created either alligator or crocodile
one of those words does not exist before
Shakespeare I like I'm so high enough to
enjoy your version of the show man like
that is tremendous do you have a job I I
do it's not as awesome as that but mine
wasn't awesome it was great I would go
to comic-con especially the first five
or six years of my comic-con attendance
hmm and this was when I was working for
Entertainment Weekly and the e/w party
was at its beginning the e-w sci-fi
party like it was e/w partnered with the
science-fiction channel which you know
may or maynot any W Entertainment Weekly
I see and so I would go to that party
you know Z W in sci-fi and I would get
like a little bit hammered and then like
roll up on B level science-fiction
actors and like tell them how much I
and so I had moderated a battlestar
galactica panels like the women of
Battlestar and so it was like it was it
was Mary McDonald and Katee Sackhoff and
Tricia Helfer and and and and I think
Grace Park was on it too remembers while
ago I was drunk and and and I go to this
party and I had had like just enough
liquid courage to like roll up on Mary
McDonald and be like you know what my
wife is cool with it
you could come live with us and she said
that's adorable and I said no but for
real though and she says yeah no but
then we launched into this like 30
minute conversation about the role of
like women and power and how women wield
power that's different from men and what
and all of this stuff that I barely
remember because I was just drunk enough
that I could have this conversation with
the president of the colonies and like
she was the president play the president
she's the president she's my president
was she the Secretary of Education she
was you got the bump because everybody
else was doing Warren Buffett had a
mistress for the last 20 or 30 years of
his wife's life and is now with her like
his wife was like listen you're the most
wealthy man in the world doing this
conversation takes the weirdest [ __ ]
like waiting for the other shoe to drop
I'm like why are we talking about Warren
Buffett or just because he said like you
can come live with us even though he's a
married man Warren Buffett literally did
that and someone was like [ __ ] okay like
you don't say no to your saying mark
pull the Warren Buffett exactly yeah
doesn't my never been said before but
that is that is the convention that I
met Tricia Helfer and she was not
apparently disgusted enough by me like
ten years later I said hey do you wanna
do a podcast together and she said yes
you were charming once and that might
have been the liquid courage I'm sure
you know I and then you hit her with
like my wife said you could come live
with us
that was a great question give it up for
amazed Germany's one
[Applause]
hold on this you take one of those and
we do one of these goddamn pleasure man
all right The Wizard of Menlo well what
yeah you go to LA live any day whenever
you want and I think you can use it back
east to like at a 40 X theater back
there yeah maybe we won't have one there
too they have them all over the place
check the Internet's man we're [ __ ]
like Salomon low key scalping hey what's
your name
hi I'm Michelle Michelle everyone give
it up for Michelle Michelle what can you
tell us about Warren Buffett pretty much
nothing except I like Jimmy Buffett as a
younger brother right what can we do for
you
so been a fan of you for a long time
thank you for a long time but I have
never read comic books never I find them
to be distracting because they're not
linear and I'm a very kind of anxious
jumpy person so I'll look at a comic
book I'm a little nervous
sorry don't be I'll look at a comic book
and I literally can't pay attention it's
like one word and I so I bought my first
comic book recently and I got Umbrella
Academy because I really love the show
I'm actually not done with the book yet
but I picked it up I was at Barnes &
Noble and I picked it up and I looked at
it and I was like wow I'm actually I'm
on the third page and I haven't ran away
yet so that's my first book but I was
kind of curious what you think there is
so many comics out there that I don't
even know where to start so it was just
kind of I should go to somebody who
maybe is a little bit of an authority on
the subject and you guys are that so
where do you think I should start what
yeah I mean done and done he's gonna
list a bunch first in a second but what
I'm gonna tell you is if you find
reading comics distracting yes this is
just a helpful tip maybe it's not
helpful the reading comics online
like those apps that my comic-con I'm
aware unbelievable how though just once
you tap it it will tell you where to
[ __ ] go you won't be distracted
because it goes panel the panel balloon
to balloon sometimes for people who
aren't like raised in the artform and
[ __ ] like just following the story is
difficult because the layout will not
but when they put a comic in and like
comiXology app or whatever you just tap
it and it takes you to everything you're
supposed to stay in order and stuff it
could be helpful to train for like the
real comedy yeah well because I've
always interesting I never thought about
that
yeah it's cuz it's not linear I've
always thought that if the pictures were
on this page and the words were on this
there are some that were like that you
can find some comic books like this
early on in your podcast I remember
you're speaking about talking about this
about Alan Moore's saga this one thing
and I always wanted to read it and I
couldn't I can't yeah on the app is easy
it might be easy for you to rely on the
app yeah get hitter with some naturally
I'm gonna go like all you gotta read The
Dark Knight Returns if left to your own
devices what kind of other books would
you read because it's like it's easy to
just say you should read this thing but
I don't know if you can like that thing
well I will say that one of the things
I've entertained is Dark Tower cuz I'm
currently reading Dark Tower the books
mm-hmm and I love Stephen King I love
mystery [ __ ] and I love celebrity
autobiographies those are the three
things I love to read so I know that's
such a random thing okay this is not a
it's not I wouldn't call this kind of a
celebrity biography but do you remember
Brian Bendis wrote fortune and glory
years yeah about his first time he came
to Hollywood to like sell something to
work on something it's like done with
you know practically stick figure
drawings and stuff but it's a pretty
gripping [ __ ] tale fortune and glory
beyond the pocket oh yeah
[Laughter]
what else watchman of course is a
classic the Alan Moore Swamp Thing run
is fantastic if it looks daunting get it
on the app it'll tell you exactly where
to look what panels to go to I think
Alan Moore's from Hell would also be
really interesting like if you like
thrillers you like mysteries like it is
Alan Moore's version of the Jack the
Ripper
oh don't crimes [ __ ] like Eddie Campbell
did the art it's gorgeous and wonderful
are you familiar with Neil Gaiman's
Sandman run I'm aware of it I'm aware of
Neil Gaiman fall into it before like
they're apparently gonna be making a
series very soon I guess right yeah now
would be the time to tap into it so that
when the series happens you're fully
prepared nope that's some of the best
comic book writing that's ever been done
Matt Wagner did a book called mage years
ago the hero discovered he's done a
series of mage books but the first one
was kind of an Arthurian legend hoots
great book there are a couple of books
that DC put out under the paradox press
banner like beautiful stories for ugly
yeah
but they did Road to Perdition Tom Hanks
movie yeah based on a comic book and
history of violence which basically
became the VGO movie like we're both
comic books first and then almost
anything vertigo did before they went
away yeah I think going back to like
when they first started that's all the
grown-up he stuff and that's before we
even touched the character the the cape
and cowl stuff like oh of course I
should read these kind of very large
everybody knows about them because and
I'm going to be prejudiced of my
preconceived notions like trying to read
even stuff that came before it's you
know it's like I just started watching
next generation because I never watched
it and only ever watch the movies and
it's weird because I'm just like wait
but I already have this opinion
something I don't have any knowledge of
yeah I mean I think fables fables is a
really strong injury why the last man is
like a perfect beginners comic because
it's very self insulated it's just
there's no continuity you need to worry
about there's no other characters you
need to follow it is just this story
about the last man on earth in a world
full of women and it's impeccably well
done I think the Green River Killer
that a guy named Jeff Jensen wrote about
his it's a sort of biographical book
about his father who was Tom Jensen who
hunted the Green River Killer for real
and like caught him so it's like a
real-life story about like a son
watching his father chase down a serial
killer and what that does to the family
what that does days in person is dad the
[ __ ] process of catching a serial
killer over years and years and years
it's like both personal and really
really dramatic
so yeah just trying to think again of
like if this was a regular book what
kind of things would you read if this
was a morning yeah I think from Hell
also like that's just giant bibliography
of Awesome and it's a big slab of alan
moore doing the very things that he
doesn't actively well this is gonna
sound i'm gonna sound like such a Bendis
fanboy but did you ever read torso yeah
torso was this series that Brian Bendis
who's now a DC Comics he was at Marvel
forever if I can created Miles Morales
and stuff amongst many other characters
he did this story that I never knew
about which was you know Eliot Ness was
a real guy and we all know the
intouchables movie which of course is
largely fantastical and stuff like that
after you know they got Capone and [ __ ]
like he went to Cleveland I guess Ohio
where essentially he tracked the first
serial killer first American serial
killer case that they acknowledge like
this is a somebody that's doing it
somebody who is cutting off heads and
limbs just leaving torsos and stuff
story I never it's the last
Eliot Ness story it's the case he was
working on when he lost his life
grip and [ __ ] tail nobody talks about
it well I think fortune and glory if I
remember correctly was him talking about
taking torso out to the
world to try to sell or something like
venture eventually like was developing
it for a long time and then yeah yeah
but yeah it's it's definitely worth
looking up particularly because just
like it was a story I'd never heard
before there's a [ __ ]
these cats wrote a daredevil a couple of
years ago man casada and Paul me ah T
and the Smith character that's worth
checking out there's a green arrow run
by a guy named Kevin Smith yeah there's
my stuff and [ __ ] but avoid that there's
a lot of good stuff to read but yeah I
think that's like a decent place to
start and if you want more come on back
I'm telling you try the app though that
it's such a one I love reading comics
but when it won't move to an app when
they introduce that app I I had such a
blast reading again just because I you
know they gave a fine it where you tap
to you're like whoo let's see where they
want me look I don't want to look there
and I'd fight the little robot and [ __ ]
like don't fight the robot don't fight
the future accept it but definitely get
the app and that's that's a good way in
give it up for lazy watch yeah
come get your [ __ ]
yes this you take a hat you take one of
these pleasure nice to meet you night
where are we going next
the last of the finest did we lose Nate
Mike what's your name man
Otto what is it Otto Otto OTT Oh like
car like autobot Otto Otto Otto yes
everyone give it up for Otto my name is
cop to like to get so growing up I
really love the Tim Burton Batman films
mm-hmm and then like maybe eight years
pass before you watch them I got to
Batman of insurance and that's a movie I
think people tend to remember it fondly
and then watch it and go like I would
remember this I would always recommend
it to my friends it's the darkest Batman
film right and like that's why it's so
good and then now I would constantly
like quote it like poontang and French
lover okay so my question is we already
saw what burden did with the DC films
film how you wished that prime burden
had tackled on the Marvel side Burton
directing a Marvel movie prime Vernon
what's primer Batman like a tease I mean
you know Burton you know he's you know
he still got it uh-huh that was honestly
like [ __ ] that Dumbo movie is [ __ ]
up like that that he was able to get
away with that movie cuz it lit so
Disney movie that [ __ ] like makes fun
of Disney and not even in a cutesy warm
way in a way of like you guys you know
you're talking about Walt [ __ ] Disney
himself right so I was kind of
subversive
but I understand what you're saying Tim
Burton when everyone was like oh my god
he's a wunderkind what Marvel character
Tim Burton on Squirrel Girl which sounds
dirtier than I meant it but huginn you
know what I'm saying he can handle that
material pretty damn well
you I think I think I go x-men I think
that he his affinity is so much for the
monster you know it's so much for the
outcast it's so much for the people who
don't fit in yeah it's set in this
bucolic setting much like them a lot of
his work is about like the perfect
manicured grounds and this gorgeous
mansion and like everything should be
perfect but isn't because you've got a
house full of just the unwanted and the
unloved and I think that speaks directly
to the filmmaker that he is at his best
you know it's the Edward Scissorhands
Edward Edward it's it's even Mars
Attacks to a certain degree like but
then I also kind of wanted him to make a
thing movie because because he loves
Outsiders who don't fit in so well just
I'm a dude who's I left on the spaceship
and I was a man and I came back and I'm
a giant [ __ ] rock and I have to live
like this and I have to like I can't get
married like this can I can't have kids
like this can i I can't hold another
[ __ ] job like this can I like what do
i do where do I go here the only people
that I know who will know who I was and
treat me like a man
bless you thank you sorry but yeah
that's that's kind of where I go like
finding the outcasts and letting them
swing but then I also wear them to do
dr. strange cuz imagine what [ __ ] up
oh that's a [ __ ] good call yeah Tim
Burton on doctors you don't like the
other two I like to say I'm like what
Scott's doing but I'm just saying I'm
trying to think of characters that would
be a good one
Ghost Rider yeah man venom excellent
[ __ ] call yeah these are good Tim
Burton characters Howard the Duck
yes the most ended where are you there
are excellent [ __ ] pull [ __ ] man
those are good anyone else
carnage why in the venom world of course
Tim Burton on the Punisher you'd be all
emo and [ __ ]
[Music]
Nightcrawler see [ __ ] a man Tim Burton
on Nightcrawler yeah yeah yeah fair
enough
wow it's so weird how great I never
thought about that Tim Burton doing
Marvel well and it's possibility we
could see it
he's a Disney kid now predominantly and
that's all [ __ ] Disney you know we
could I bet you that's not like
far-fetched like you Tim Burton right
about now and like you know Dumbo just
happened don't you think you'd be like
give me a Marvel movie fast well
stranger dr. Shane scan the deal with
the multiverse right yeah so well now
let's okay so who could he do not even I
mean that's [ __ ] let's pretend
minutes right now okay like who's left
that we'd like to see them make a movie
out of that he could literally just
[ __ ] go dark dark Phoenix's third
time's a charm I mean I don't know what
what is he a potential FF guy would he
handle the Fantastic Four well
did somebody say don't do it no he's
back away man slowly Scarlet Witch good
call they've already established her
crime house of em yeah that mace it's
too bad those are in New Mutants moving
because he would be good on the mutants
yeah yeah whatever happened in that new
movie smooth it's you know they made a
movie did you see that was his name no
Hollies the guy that does Legion yeah he
just said officially that doctor there
was a dr. doom standalone movie that he
was writing and now it's dead cuz of
that deal and stuff so it went away we
almost had a dr. doom movie by the guy
that did Legion I'd be a [ __ ] mind
[ __ ] but back to Tim Burton man whoo who
said that [ __ ] stand up and take a
bow applaud for that man but to be fair
he did do dark shadows
maybe we don't want them touching
vampires again who do you want to see
Johnny Depp play I mean you know there's
a world where he could pull off no more
if they were ever to do that I mean
you'd need somebody visionary to take
you under the sea after what James Wan
and crew did with Aquaman
you know Marvel's gonna have to have a
completely different [ __ ] oceanic
take Tim Burton could be good for that
[ __ ] moon night yes the [ __ ]
who gave us Batman on moon night who
said that stand the [ __ ] up give that
man a pause da oh my god man what an
easy let's go pitch that [ __ ] it's a
no-brainer man it gives him another bite
at the Batman Apple too - more or less
I mean nobody want him to have another
bite at that Apple but no you you could
I mean look man [ __ ] 1989's Batman Tim
Burton's Batman still stands out like
and you remember how [ __ ] important
it was like aren't taking nothing away
from endgame do you remember the [ __ ]
excitement oh of that [ __ ] in the
summer everybody waiting for June 23rd
people cut in the bat symbol into their
[ __ ] heads and that's not just like
people I knew that was like real live
people on the news and [ __ ] oh it's
[ __ ] to you there was no internet in
89 so all the information came from the
news yeah or the newspaper and when they
cast [ __ ] Michael Keaton it was so
[ __ ] big it broke the internet then
and there was no internet like yeah it
broke the cover of Time magazine like
this is bad man so that dude man like
who did Batman think about like he's had
a career since then many made many
movies how many years is 30 years since
Batman yeah well on the 30th anniversary
in 30 years since he's made a costume
superhero adventure his first one the
one that defined his [ __ ] career
to step back into the genre knowing he's
learned so much since that one and to
take over moon night that is the
greatest [ __ ] movie we'll never see
them I'm gonna be haunted by your
beautiful [ __ ] idea [ __ ] that was
good man you deserve you know what
you're gonna win something too
you get to walk away with a forgotten
poster for that too but that was it did
we hit it we hit it we hit it that was a
great question you win some [ __ ] give it
up for him man that [ __ ] and the man who
gets his poster when Nixon put your paw
right there
goddamn pleasure [ __ ] that took us on a
journey of imagination like Willy Wonka
but the one we all like Hey you mean the
one the Tim Burton II didn't do yes
that's right all right [ __ ] man what is
that that is a book I signed for
somebody it's just for you to sign it
yeah yeah I mean you can if you want to
expense story in here but you can you
wrote an x-men sorry yeah what one I
don't know this book is big but you you
wrote one I wrote a Nightcrawler origins
did you really yeah when this was seven
eight years ago maybe basic his Dumbo
it's it's Kurt Warner as the [ __ ]
circus freak who met mystique at least
in their continuity was also his mother
because sure but yeah it was it was a
Dumbo story about the circus freak who
has to escape the son of a gypsy and the
circus owner was being super [ __ ]
brutal and so his mom mystique takes him
out and they run free into the
wilderness to then be chased by Nazis
but it was a tearjerker because why the
[ __ ] wouldn't you want it that's the
saddest of the x-men origin story so
yeah yeah magneto is pretty sad too in
the movie yes yeah what did he start sad
but oh my god [ __ ] like who knew I
did for a second there didn't seem like
you did it like I don't know it's one of
these in here well because I also wrote
a
Varian story was part of their like
Wolverine 500 issue that came out it was
the the idea was once a year Wolverine
wants to get rip-roaring drunk but can't
because he's got this [ __ ] healing
factor so he finds the one like a
washout from Xavier Academy whose power
was he could dampen any mutant
superpower within a 10-foot radius so he
like gets this guy named Chester like
out of his job at a Kinkos tonight's the
night bub and like they won not only
like he just goes out to get hammered
because here's the only way for him to
do it like he wants to get into a bar
fight because I never get into bar
fights it's it's it's a good drunk
Wolverine story right next men give it
up for him all right kids
don't forget man if you want to come see
us do this live we do it again next week
here on Tuesday we do it next Tuesday
and we do it in Anaheim Wilson that's
right Tuesday here at the scum and
villainy Cantina again next week or you
could see this on Sunday afternoon at
power con if you're down in Anaheim and
stuff fat man on he-man that'll be
interesting but up until failing that we
have no show left to give you ladies and
gentlemen did you enjoy yourselves this
evening I cannot thank you enough for
coming out but there is no show without
the guys to my left as we heard he was
carrying the show all night because for
the first half I was like where are we I
feel like give it up for mr. mark
Bernard
[Applause]
and that is fat man um fat man beyond
for this week drink Batman Beyond for
this week I'm Kevin Smith
I'm more tune in next week same bat-time
same bat-channel SModcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith happy
birthday Shannon see you guys later bye
[Applause]
[Music]
you